let us pray this has been a difficult
and contentious week in which darker
spirits seem to have been at play in the
people's house in your Most Holy Name I
now cast out all spirits of darkness
from this chamber spirits not from you I
cast out the spirit of discouragement
which deadens the hope of those who are
of goodwill I cast out the spirit of
petty divisive miss which clouds the
sense and the desire to be a fruitful
productivity in addressing the issues
more appropriately before this house I
cast out any sadness brought on by the
frustration of dealing with matters
detrimental to the honorable work each
member has been called to engage in